6 14 it's Wednesday morning you see them
on the street corners headphones on
their dances are dialed in they got
their moves all going and the signs are
flying high now you can see them all
together because the best of
nine Spinners are back here in Las Vegas
it's really like their Super Bowl it's a
big deal and there's money on the line
Candace Charles joining us live this
morning Candace have you been practicing
we're ready to see your moves
well Heather I took off my jacket so you
know that it's gonna be serious business
because I gotta tell you it is cold out
here guys but the professionals the real
dudes and gals will be doing the
competition right here in the middle of
the free watching experience on a
Saturday they're coming from all over
the world and I have one of the
competitors here with me now local
manager Ray and Jones thank you so much
for joining us for the folks that don't
know this is the 16th competition that
they're having but some people may not
know about it tell us a little bit about
the competition so we're having a world
sign spring Championship Spinners from
around the world coming to compete to
see you the best sunscreen in the world
is and you guys have three different
kind of areas right the best technique
uh and I think a few other ones but go
ahead so technical ability your how well
you do the tricks and your execution all
right right Coco okay and they're vying
to win a five thousand dollars that's
for the top prize but there are also
some smaller ones for people who want to
join Errol Stein spinning how can they
go about that so just visit our website
at arrowsign spinners.com fill out that
quick application we'll get back with
you 24 to 48 hours and we'll schedule
you for an in-person interview yeah you
might be able to
look for practicing here you go Ray let
me give you this mic and here's one of
my tricks
so that's what that's the that's the
what's that called that's the that's the
canvas that's the canvas move okay it
doesn't look like that obviously it
doesn't look like that you guys can come
check out the real competition on
Saturday starting at noon it's from five
to six of the finals it's all free and
open the public cards you got you
covered with details Auto website
newsnow.com live for free matching
experience in downtown Las Vegas I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now